For this module,
you'll want to open up the playground
file entitled Lesson1_Strings.
And then of course, you'll want to check
in your Editor's menu that down here at
the second to the last item says,
Show Raw Markup.
If you see a bunch of green comments,
you're going to want to
click Show Rendered Markup.
There's a lot of fun to be
had playing the strings and
Swift strings are no exception.
Earlier, you saw strings
defined as string literals.
And you also saw Swift
style string concatenation.
Because Swift string class is
built from Unicode scalar values,
one can type emoji directly into
string literals, like this.
Oh yeah, to bring up the emoji keyboard
like that, I do control, command,
space bar.
And then I can choose the heart.
Another time saving feature of
Swift strings is support for
string interpolation.
In other words,
inserting values of variables and
expressions directly
into string literals.
Let's say we have a statement about how
much a particular dog eats per month.
And remember you can
always see the result of
the executed code over
here in the sidebar.
Now let's say instead of Lulu
we want to know how much Ferris
the Springerdoodle eats per month.
Here I've declared
dogName as a variable and
then I've inserted it into my string.
And over here on the right you can see
that the string evaluates to Ferris eats
25 pounds of dog food per month.
We can add expressions
to our string as well.
Let's say we're really only paying
attention to how much Ferris
eats per day.
This monthly consumption rate
can actually be evaluated as
the string is built.
And of course, I do that by typing
backslash, and then parentheses.
And then between the parentheses,
I put the expression I want to evaluate.
So pounds per day, Times days per month.
And again, you can see
the output hasn't changed much.
Now our doggie diet string
is much more customizable.
For example if we want to calculate the
pounds per month eaten by little Frankie
here, all we have to do is change
the value of pounds per day.
Reassigned the dog named variable and
then re-evaluate our doggie diet string.
And then over here we can
see that little Frankie eats 7.5
pounds of dog food per month.